they've been reports of strange
incidences nearby I send agents to
investigate you know it's easy to say at
first oh well it's kind of like Mass
Effect 3's multiplayer you've got four
people of different classes and you're
fighting enemies together but actually
it's it's quite different it's not horde
mode per se it's just it's dungeon
crawling right yeah yeah dungeon
crawling Luke collecting that type of
stuff but it's all it's all different
you know you've got 12 different
characters to choose from from from the
three different classes and then you
just you get together you move through
when you fight monsters you can get Luke
but it's all stuff that relates only to
your multiplayer character and in no way
affects you know you're single player
yeah like their experience like that
loot is just for your multiplayer
campaigns oh yeah that's not like you
can't take that into the main game and
show it off in your sweet Inquisition
quest and say like hey fellow
inquisitors check out these new spalled
runes i got looking pretty good yeah the
fact that Bioware is kind of going out
of its way to explicitly state that
there is no connection between the
dragon age inquisition single-player and
multiplayer does that feel to you like
kind of a direct response to Mass Effect
3's multiplayer yes which was which was
great but but they tried really hard to
connect that multiplayer they did a
player right so they've they're going
out of their way to say oh well we're
just you know right now this is a
completely separate experience you know
these these things have nothing to do
with each other the coop is all the coop
and the story is all the story and never
the twain shall meet as much as it's
about loot right you know you go into
these kind of experiences expecting and
I want to get more and more powerful but
I'm hoping that it actually brings
something challenging and interesting to
keep you engaged for a moment to moment
especially when you know they've got a
limited number of these of these
dungeons yeah then I think it's like
three multi flower campaigns to start
off with I wonder if like are they going
to make it really difficult right off
the bat just to add some extra length to
the overall experience it's possible I
also know they're there random elements
to the whole fan so you know there's a
reason to go back
again and again I mean even for
something like diablo 3 because they're
there are elements that are procedurally
generated and randomized so that you
know there's always a reason to go back
per se I just I just want it to be more
than just about the loot yeah well I
guess we'll find out soon or at least
I'll find out soon because they're going
to have it playable at pax and i'll be
sure to report back to you i'll send you
a text message to let you know how it is
thank you you'd be like oh things are
really great here with dragon age
inquisition of pax Kevin how are you
I'll be like I'm here eating pizza and
feeling sad and a willing saddle on